the thing about shareholder capitalism  is that it's on contract if you have a  percentage of a company or shares in a  company you have a contract to verify  stakeholder is just it's subjective like  one day I could dump trash up River and  say everyone down river is a stakeholder  in my behavior because they're all going  to be affected by it but then the next  day I could say no no I put a dam in  there or a sifting mechanism now those  people aren't stakeholders anymore  because I changed the way my system  works so you have no recourse as a  stakeholder in those systems is  completely controlled from the top I I  highly warn against it I think Klaus has  taken us down or attempting to take us  down a very dangerous road Klaus Schwab  with his world economic Forum  stakeholder capitalism and you're right  Tim it is communism